- [Narrator] This iconic dish
is all about the details.
French toast might look
super simple to make,
but looks can be deceiving.
French toast is crispy on the outside,
that silky custard on the inside.
It's just so indulgent and delicious.
What's not to love?
So over the last couple of weeks,
we've eaten a ton of
butter and bread and syrup
to find out what makes the best
classic French Toast recipe.
(upbeat music)
French toast is only as good as its bread.
So that's where we'll start.
There are a ton of options out there
and we tested a bunch of them.
For French toast,
we want to use a bread that's
both sturdy on the outside
and spongy and tender on the inside.
Something like a brioche,
challah, or white bread.
We also tested milk bread,
Hawaiian bread, and sourdough
but found they really
altered the flavor profile
of the dish.
Ultimately, challah was our favorite.
We don't recommend
buying a pre-sliced loaf,
because we want our slices
to be the perfect thickness.
If they're too thin,
they'll fall apart with
the weight of the custard.
But if they're too thick,
it'll be difficult to cook the
custard all the way through
and nobody wants raw custard.
We think about an inch
to an inch and a half
is the perfect thickness.
Now this next part might
seem counterintuitive,
but we don't want to use fresh bread.
We want it to be at least a day old.
Using fresh bread will result
in dense and soggy toast.
But don't worry if you
need French toast right now
and your bread isn't ready,
just bake your slices at
200 degrees Fahrenheit
for 10 minutes to dry them out.
And then you'll be ready
to make your custard.
The custard is really
where the magic happens
when it comes to French toast.
The perfect custard
creates a crispy exterior
with a silky rich interior.
If you use too much milk,
or a lot of sugar in your custard,
the egg won't cook and you'll
get wet and soggy toast.
So a good rule we follow
is that for about every
quarter cup of dairy,
we use one large egg.
For our recipe, we'll
be using six large eggs.
It's important to
thoroughly whisk the eggs
so you don't end up with
clumps of egg whites
in your custard.
That will ruin an otherwise
perfectly golden brown
piece of toast.
Then we'll add our milk, heavy cream,
brown sugar, and salt.
Finally, we're gonna add our seasoning.
Seasoning your custard is crucial.
Now you can definitely get fancy with it
by adding things like
cardamom, orange zest, nutmeg,
cloves, ginger, lemon zest,
or even liqueurs,
but we found that less is more
when it comes to seasoning,
so we're just adding a little cinnamon
and some vanilla paste.
You can totally make this
with vanilla extract,
but we think it's worth the upgrade
to use vanilla bean paste.
It just packs a bigger vanilla punch
and it's still cheaper than vanilla beans.
We'll whisk all of our
custard ingredients together
until it's well combined.
Remember, we don't want any egg clumps.
Now that our custard's ready,
let's add our bread.
We want to make sure the custard
completely soaks the bread,
but we don't want to soak it for so long
that it begins to disintegrate.
Yeah, it's just super gross.
So we'll soak the bread
until it begins to feel heavy in our hands
and completely saturated throughout.
This could mean anywhere from 20 seconds
to a minute on each side.
Now that our bread has
taken a little custard bath,
it's time to cook.
We tested several methods.
Your cast iron has to
be seasoned super well
or your bread will end
up sticking to the pan.
The oven is a great method
for making big batches,
but doesn't get the crispy edges we want
in a truly great French toast.
So ultimately, we love using
a nonstick electric griddle.
It distributes heat evenly
across its entire surface,
and it's also big enough
to cook large batches of toast at a time.
But if you don't have a griddle,
a nonstick pan works just as well.
Now to get a golden brown crispy toast,
it's crucial to preheat
whatever pan your choose.
By preheating the pan,
the custard will begin
to cook immediately.
If the pan is cold from the start,
the custard will spread to form a foot,
something like this, on
the bottom of the toast.
We recommend preheating your pan
before you start making your custard.
Once our pan is hot enough,
we'll lightly grease
it with a pat of butter
or something a little more than a pat.
We like our butter here at Tasty.
Once all of that butter is melted,
we'll place the soaked toast on the pan
and let it cook undisturbed
until the bottom is golden brown,
which takes about two minutes.
Then we'll flip and
repeat on the other side.
Whoo, she's pretty!
Just look at how crispy
and golden brown that is.
Make sure to keep an eye
on your heat as you cook.
If it's too high, the sugar
in the custard will burn
before the custard is
cooked through all the way
in the middle.
Once your toast is looking beautiful,
we'll remove it from the pan.
And here's a little tip,
wipe your pan between batches
to make sure the butter
doesn't continue to cook
and leave burnt patches
on the remaining toast.
Now that we've whipped up perfect
golden brown crispy toast,
it's time to serve.
You can really get creative
with the toppings for this.
Use whipped cream, chocolate
syrup, sprinkles, bananas,
you can go wild.
But we think that less is more.
We love to serve ours with a pat of butter
and some maple syrup.
Did you know that there's a difference
between pure maple
syrup and pancake syrup?
Pancake syrup is actually made
with corn syrup and maple flavoring.
It's definitely a more affordable
and shelf stable alternative.
But if you can splurge,
we love using warm, pure maple syrup.
Drizzle that right over
the top of your toast.
And if you want to get fancy with it,
finish with a little flaky sea salt.
The sea salt really
complements the sweetness
in the custard and syrup.
We like to add a little pop of color.
So we'll serve ours with a mix of berries.
We're just using our favorites here.
And we're done.
All that's left to do now
is enjoy your work of art
with your friends and your family
on a wonderful brunch afternoon
or just indulge by yourself.
Either way, if you loaf this recipe,
you can find it and many more
on our website at tasty.co.
What's that thing that
you put on French toast?
- [Second Narrator] Syrup.
- [Narrator] Are you saying sir-up?
- [Second Narrator] How do you say it?
- [Narrator] Bro, it's seer-up.
- [Second Narrator] I think
people say it like me.